Speaker 1: There is Kevin from San Diego.
Let's go next to how about. Oh, no,
I don't want to go to this person. I'm getting a
notification that their audio is just a disaster.
Let's go to Guilherme from beautiful Montreal.
I understand you got snow last night, Jim.
Speaker 3: Yes. Can you hear me right?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Perfect. And I'm not going to
step aside because it's still coming in.
Speaker 1: All right. Still snowing.
Speaker 3: Now? Yep. Pretty, pretty
big one. I'm probably going to have
to shovel some tonight, too.
Speaker 1: Beautiful.
Speaker 3: So how's the weather on your side?
Speaker 1: The weather's good. No snow here. But,
you know, I don't remember when we last
spoke. I am considering making my next
return to Montreal very, very soon as I have
friends and family there. And it's been a while
since I've been there in winter. Last time I
was there in January, my nose would instantly
freeze when I would step out into the street.
Speaker 3: To give a recommendation as to when
may be closer to mid to when. February.
Speaker 1: Well. Oh I see. That's,
that's already better.
Speaker 3: The weather at that point is
usually not less cold, but less aggressive. Okay.
Speaker 1: When I'm all right, I'll try to make
that happen. But this isn't about
me. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Through the last couple times we
talked, I threw hypotheticals out there, but
I it was mostly me trying to formulate the
best way I could. And then I decided to just
wait after the midterms, did try to get
accused of trying to influence anything.
And but there is a question that came up.
I was on Twitter a lot recently. I know
that that's on me, I guess. And a lot of the
conversations ended up moving towards people
attacking the moderation of Twitter. Yeah. Working
along with the U.S. government, which I'm not
entirely sure they were that active with. They
might have been in communication, I don't know
for censorship when most of what we could see was
essentially. The the the the I'm not entirely sure
what agency would have worked with that front,
but it was trying to reduce the impact of Russian
misinformation on influencing the midterms.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 3: The question was, well, the
problem was the person to whom I was
talking to all of all about we should allow
Russian misinformation to affect the U.S.
elections and whatnot. And that brought to the
major question of with the U.S. trying to push
their nose into literally every other country's
economy and government system and everything,
maybe without necessarily trying to give them
a vote or any actual power. Why don't we?
I'm trying to free that. Why don't you guys more
regularly consider what other countries think
about candidates? In terms of trying to put these.
Speaker 1: There's two different things here. So
there's actually three different things here.
So the first one is, is there not a hypocrisy in
that the U.S. has interests in leaders around the
world and works to influence the way elections go?
Occasionally or sometimes. And yet it says it's
wrong when other countries try to do it to the
U.S.. Yes, that is a double standard. But every
country does that. Every country wants to have
a say about their own leaders and to have a say
about everyone else's leaders. So it's a hypocrisy
that is not unique to the United States. However,
the United States has the resources to maybe
better affect what happens in other countries
more so than other countries. That's number one.
Speaker 3: You still don't
really think about it at times.
Speaker 1: Sorry. What was that?
Speaker 3: Gill and I said something at times.
They can get really aggressive about it.
Speaker 1: I mean, absolutely.
Absolutely. It's one.
Speaker 3: Thing and.
Speaker 1: It is a double standard. Okay. The
second part of it. Shouldn't Americans care
more what the world thinks about the leaders we
pick? My opinion is that the answer is yes. Now,
that doesn't mean that people around the world
should get votes. That's not what I'm saying.
But for example, when I think about when George W
Bush was president and the world was essentially
against the invasion of Iraq. And Republicans
here said that doesn't matter. We do what's
best for us. I think it would be smarter and more
sophisticated to say, well, it would be good to
know why the world is against this invasion, even
though ultimately we do what we do. Let's actually
think about that. And similarly, when world
opinion of Trump was very low and world opinion of
Biden is higher, I don't say, Oh, those are sissy
Europeans. Who cares? I say, That's interesting.
I want to know more about why, because it's
important to me what the world thinks about
what we're doing here. So to answer that question,
the answer is absolutely yes. But these are sort
of a couple different things you're asking about.
Speaker 3: I guess there's the fact that I was not
entirely sure how to bring it up.
Speaker 1: Well,
you did beautifully. Yeah, you really did.
Speaker 3: I mean, there's the whole there is
the whole aspect, according to the people I was
talking to. Russian misinformation is all good,
all good. Everything should be accepted and seen
as fact. But oh, you damn communist Canadians over
there. You out there. I mean, you're looking at.
Speaker 1: That as it specifically applies to your
friend. I don't I don't find your friend to be
particularly, you know, sophisticated in their
thinking. But but I hope I've at least outlined a
few of a few of my thoughts. Guillaume, I've got
to run. Okay. I appreciate you calling.
Speaker 3: Yep. Have a great day.
Speaker 1: All right. There we go. Always
good to hear from Guilherme from Montreal.